metro police on the scene after one of
their own was hurt and a suspect
shot it happened near dean martin drive
and sunset in the south part of the
valley
sally jaramillo joining us now live with
the latest
brian and ease an officer was injured as
for the person who
injured that officer is dead now this
happened at
range 702 right on dean martin drive
police say a man entered the gun range
afternoon and started to cause a
disturbance inside the police were
called and the man was asked to leave
authorities say several people inside
the business followed him out
into the parking lot and when officers
arrived the man went after them
he reportedly pulled out a screwdriver
and violently attacked one of the
officers
police as well as three citizens then
opened fire
i would just like to take a moment to
remind everyone the dangers
of this job of being a police officer
and we would also like to thank good
citizens that step in and help us
in our time of need
now the officer was transported to umc
she is being treated for her injuries
i'm told she's in stable condition
no word yet on who the man is this is an
ongoing
investigation so make sure you tune in
to 8 news now for the latest details
reporting live sally jaramillo 8 news
now